voilà ça brille là pour vous ah merci ça
va ce matin sifaoui volontiers linge ou
6 3 6 6 3 citrons c'est plus frais ou le
chili voilà longtemps que je vous
attends c'est en retard enfin ça fait
rien je vous attendais pour jouer un
nouveau jeu le jeu du décor qui change
les camps jouent ensemble d'accords
parfait vous venez tous les enfants bien
vient inès casimir qui me donne un coup
de main
christophe allez-vous mettre la barre à
la belle blandine gagnent
mettez vous là bas et c'est vrai que le
facteur et casimir et maintenant vous
écouterez l eau
écoutez je vous expliquer la règle du
jeu
alors faites très attention maintenant
vous connaissez bien l'île aux enfants
on connaissait bien ses personnages et
ses paysages c'est sûr connaissez tous
alors voilà ce qu'on va faire
tu connais pas tout alors écoute écoute
moi bien quand je vous le dirais vous
promènerez dans l'île aux enfants
vous allez tous regardé très
attentivement après je l'enverrai un peu
plus loin et quand vous reviendrez
certains détails auront changé et vous
donnez vous devrez me dire les détails
qu'on change et c'est compris c'est sûr
alors regardé partout promenez vous
regardé par 2 fait le tour de l'île aux
enfants regardent et e le kiosque de
sabrina casimir le facteur les arbres
moi aussi je peux avoir quelque chose
qui ait changé après sûrement regardé la
cage à thoune aussi un regard des
n'était bien qu'est-ce que tu le banc
les arbres les ballons s'est vu c'est
sûr pas encore alors encore un petit peu
oui encore une qui peut je vous laisse
encore un peu de temps bon eh bien vous
avez tout vu répondez-moi les enfants et
tout vu ou si c'est sûr eh bien on va se
revoir tout à l'heure vous êtes revenu
bon j'appelle les enfants n'ont d'abord
je vous donne un peu d avance
regardez une première fois voyez observé
bientôt ouvrez bien les yeux
voyez les changements c'est sûr vous
avez tout vu on perdait les autres
encore un petit peu là les enfants rené
venez vite vite vite vite sophie
blandine a la belle vie de l'église
christophe ines yann est avec moi donne
moi la main sur le site et à christophe
et donc vous avez déjà vu des erreurs
alors voilà comment on va faire écoutez
moi bien vous allez vous promener dans
l'île aux enfants noté les erreurs et à
chaque fois que vous auriez une vous
venez de me donner la réponse
ok allez on y va aller toutes les
erreurs j'ai compris un saint quoi tu as
compris tu as trouvé les changements
qu'il ya un regard va regarder que c'est
bt louis regarde kazemi alors quelques
secondes
écrit alors dire bien fort le facteur a
changé de casquette
vous aviez trouvé au bon alors voilà
écoute tu as donné une réponse à
quelqu'un d'autre
inès par ici alors là ça qui a changé à
yassa qui a changé qu'est ce que c'est
c'est un talus d'herbe il a changé où il
était tout à l'heure le canada il était
dans le faux écartez vous un petit peu
vous m'écraser complètement l'inde alors
tiens paris c'est christophe jan voilà
un petit peu d'ordre dans tout ça à
blandine 1
effectivement effectivement il ya un
arbre dont le tronc a été coupée voyez
ça tient tout seul comme ça pas ici
rester comme je veux mais voilà parce
que vous mais tous fait un garçon garçon
maintenant christophe bien y avoir ici
christophe il ya un arbre qui a des
ballons accrochés dedans effectivement
vous les voyez vous les voyez si les
ballons dans l'arbre dont un à toi ce
film alors se fie à vue je crois une des
erreurs les plus difficiles massif
l'essai donnait d'aragon ce sens mais
rideau de la boutique c'est lé rideau de
la boutique se sont abaissées encore
garçons yann et ainsi y est 6e temps
alors ta réponse
les chirurgies le banc à changer de
place effectivement le banc qui est dans
le fond maintenant se trouvait à la
place du talus plein d'herbe ou alors à
toi pacifique et les ballons qu'il
travaille alors qu'ils étaient pas les
ballons oui effectivement mais je crois
pas on n'avait pas noté ça comme
changement mais
il n'était pas là tout à l'heure bon ben
alors c'est une chose c'est une erreur
attends toi à l'hérésie a quand même moi
je mets macky sall est aperçu je dois
accepter c'était vraiment l'erreur la
plus facile à trouver il allait enfin
que la haye d'envoyer la plus petite à
trouver la plus petite à trouver une des
erreurs les plus difficiles c'est le sac
du facteur qui est accroché ici le
facteur la pluie en bandoulière dust est
ce que c'était une des plus difficiles
tu es bien qu est ce qui a encore essayé
mais peut-il donner des réponses à côté
de moi là voilà qu'on en fasse profiter
nos amis regarder son à bas nos amis un
leurre si vouloir tourner le dos ça va
plus alors alors du vent enfin signalé
dans les détails
qu'est-ce qu'il ya encore alors on a dit
on et passe en revue
est ce que c'est bien ce que vous aviez
trouvé oui je récapitule on avait la
casquette du facteur ça on a mis les
deux volets du kiosque qui sont baissés
d'un tronc d'arbre qui a été enlevé la
sacoche du facteur qui est accroché la
cage à poules le faux-nez casimir le
gant qui a changé de place
le talus plein d'herbe qui se trouve à
cet endroit là les ballons dans l'arbre
et sabrina risquer une erreur sur
sabrina vient pas une erreur un
changement une avarie naissent regardez
bien la personne n'a trouvé
voilà sur fidji ainsi qu'un essai alors
elle devait être dans le kiosque elle
est sortie du kiosque et moi j'ai changé
de chemise
effectivement toute heure j'avais une
chemise comme un viol c'est inès c'est
une esclave
comment était ma chemise une instance
mise et mettait à carreaux bleus
elle était à carreaux bleus et blancs et
maintenant on a les cas à carreaux jaune
et ben voilà bravo oui mais tu sais très
bien et vous nous aviez trouvé aussi
vous aviez tout trouvé c'est sûr